we've had lots of messages  of congratulations but specifically um  from the queen and she has written the  most wonderful message this evening my  warmest congratulations and those of my  family go to you all on winning the  european women's football championships  it's significant achievement for the  entire team including your support staff  the championships and your performance  in them have rightly won praise however  your success goes far beyond the trophy  you have so deservedly earned you've all  set an example that will be an  inspiration for girls and women today  and for future generations it's my hope  that you will be as proud of the impact  you have had on your sport as you are  of the result today  well that is a lovely lovely statement